hello and welcome back to game review my
name is Caleb Denby and today we're
gonna be going over a very high level
game of chess that was played between
yours truly and Mario Roper in a blitz
tournament right here at the st. Louis
chess club without further ado let's
just take a look at it the game started
d4 Knight f6 c4 c6 actually a very
interesting move order to get into the
Slav I think it's kind of worthwhile it
makes some lines for white a little bit
trickier the game continued though with
Bishop f4 as my choice
and now d5 transposes into the normal
Slav however this extra option of
playing c6 followed by Knight f6 really
gives black an interesting choice here
to play this move Queen b6 I think this
is a worthwhile line for black so you
Slav aficionados out there maybe take a
look at this one and think about adding
it to your repertoire uh instead though
we just got the normals love with d5 I'm
a very ambitious player so I capture
this pawn the second I can I like taking
things so going into the exchange Slav
now everybody expected C takes d5 here
and we have a normal exchange love but
Mario had other ideas for me Knight
takes d5 not the best move but
interesting nonetheless my bishops
attacked
maybe I'll miss it thankfully I didn't
this time around
and so Bishop g3 and Mario continues
with the move Bishop f5 perhaps an
interesting way for him to play would
have actually been to expand with E 5
and now his opening starts to make a
little bit more sense giving up this
pawn in exchange for this act of knight
and some pressure with moves like Queen
b6 now that my Bishop has been diverted
all the way to g3 instead though Bishop
f5 and I simply develop my knight to the
c3 square black continues with Knight
takes c3 which is a bit of a mistake it
supports my center a little bit too much
now after a six I play a very nice move
f3 which controls this efore square and
really highlights how much the
the white central advantage is going to
be relevant this Fisher comes out to e7
now I get to play E for with tempo on
the bishop bishop comes back to g6 the
bishop comes out to d3 black castles I
play 92 Mario plays 97 getting developed
I play this move rook b1 hitting a pawn
on b7 black defends his pawn with b6 and
very high level stuff I went ahead and
got castled and now black wasn't really
sure what to do here I think Mario
thought for a little bit if my memory of
the game serves me correctly
maybe black could try c5 maybe black a
try 'if I fall though there's not really
enough support for it yet but in the end
all of these pawn breaks are just a
little bit awkward so what Mario came up
with was actually more awkward than all
of those pawn breaks though he went for
this move f5 which is really just not a
good idea it leaves too many weaknesses
behind and after Knight f4 it's
difficult to protect everything if you
play Bishop f7 I'll take on f5 and after
takes on f5 I'm winning upon and if you
play Bishop takes a two I should note
there's things like Bishop takes h7
check as well as simply Bishop e6 check
and forks are coming your way so he
didn't like Bishop f7 and instead the
move he chose is king f7 and I'll let
you at home try and find the refutation
to this move it's not super complex but
it is a nice one ok of course the answer
is to play Knight takes c6 and after
King takes c6 if you got this far at
home hopefully you saw the continuation
here it's a pretty one there's actually
two ways to do it the first way is the
one I chose Bishop c4 check and these
bishops
are cutting across the center of the
board the king must go to f6 and now
I'll let me introduce you to my friend
Chris and my other friend cross and the
King has been Criss crossed to death and
this is the end of the game it's a short
one today but thank you very much for
joining me as I went over the
high-level blitz game I played with
Mario Roper in a blitz tournament here
at the Chess Club and my name is Caleb
Denby as always I will see you in the
next episode